au départ notre projet pouvait se
comparer aux boeing 767 mais quand nous
avons obtenu entre guillemets les
premières informations sur l'airbus a320
nous avons décidé de nous rapprocher
totalement de l'avion européen aveux
spontanés de laives la noce qui
constructeur des avions commerciaux du
pôle f
en 1989 au journal aviation magazine
depuis on appelle plus le biréacteur
soviétique tu-204 que herbaut ce qui
construit seulement à cinq exemplaires
le modèle exposé au salon du bourget est
bourrée d'instruments de mesure et
l'accomplît conforme n'est pas encore
susceptibles de capter l'attention
d'éventuels acheteurs
on ne copie jamais un avion sur un autre
modèle les constructeurs on arrive
toujours aux mêmes conclusions
ce sont uniquement les techniques qui
évolue il conduisait alors à produire
des avions y danse et cirque à l'aéro
flotte aurait commandé 300 exemplaires
du tupolev 204 mais les soviétiques
buterait encore sur des idées novatrices
pas facile de se rapprocher le plus
possible de l'airbus a320 temps dans le
système de la motorisation que dans
l'instrumentation en vol ou
l'aménagement intérieur
enfin prévu pour être piloté à 2
aeroflot exigerait la présence à son
bord d'un ingénieur supplémentaires cet
avion sera peut-être une fois certifiés
un concurrent sérieux pour l'airbus a320
et cela ne déplaît pas au consortium
européen
mais si les espions ont bien fait leur
travail les techniciens pour l'instant
trébuche